Bon, les gars, je pense qu'on commence
à être pas mal.
Il y a tout: mes affaires,
l'électroménager.
Mais je trouve que ça manque un
peu de vie encore dans l'appart.
Du coup, j'ai pensé à une pote
à moi qui est décoratrice d'intérieur.
Elle va arriver, elle va pimper tout ça.
Je pense que ça va être pas mal.
Ah, je crois qu'elle est là.
Allez, on y va.
Aïe, aïe, aïe, salut la star!
Ça va ou quoi?
Je suis hyper flattée que tu aies
pensé à moi pour faire la déco.
Par contre, tu filmes quoi?
Je fais un vlog.
Ça ne te dérange pas?
Non, ça ne me dérange pas,
t'inquiète.
Je suis une habituée des vlogs
et en plus, on va faire un avant-après
de malade.
Tu peux juste m'aider à rentrer
les sacs?
Ils sont là, devant l'entrée.
OK.
Tiens, je te passe juste la caméra.
Bon, les gars, c'est trop stylé!
Là, je suis dans l'appart de Riad.
On va le refaire.
Vous me connaissez.
Ça va être le feu.
Ça va, tu te débrouilles?
C'est pas trop difficile?
Ils sont lourds de ouf,
les sacs là.
Ce qu'il y a dedans,
c'est une surprise.
Donc, je ne peux rien te dire.
Je ne suis pas fan fan des surprises,
mais…
T'inquiète.
Mais c'est pas toi qui cherchais
un fauteuil de gamer trop stylé?
Ah si si!
Il y en a un juste en bas de chez toi.
Tu devrais grave y aller!
Ah oui, en bas là?
Oui, là maintenant.
Là, tout de suite?
Prends-le avant que quelqu'un ne
le prenne.
OK, j'y vais.
Oui, il n'y a pas de souci.
Juste, ne fais pas trop de dingueries.
Attends que j'arrive,
quoi.
T'inquiète, pas de souci.
Les gars, histoire de malade.
Regardez ce que j'ai trouvé:
un siège gaming de ouf!
Il y a un mec qui s'est assis dessus.
Je lui ai dit: "Monsieur,
c'est à vous?" Il me dit:
"Ouais." "C'est vous qui l'avez
jeté." Et il me dit non.
Le mec, il ne voulait pas lâcher
l'affaire.
Je lui ai lâché 10 balles pour
avoir le siège.
Mais il est énervé.
Il est incroyable!
Je pense qu'il va aller trop bien
avec l'appartement.
Je suis trop content!
J'arrive!
Attends deux secondes et ferme
les yeux.
Je ne ferme pas les yeux,
je suis encombré.
C'est bon, j'aurai la surprise
quand même.
Ferme les yeux, je te dis!
Bon OK.
Fais-moi confiance.
Je déteste les surprises.
T'inquiète, je sais que tu vas adorer.
Tu ne bouges pas.
À trois, tu ouvres les yeux.
Tu es prêt?
Un, deux, trois.
Sally, c'est quoi ça?
C'est grave stylé!
Ça change, hein?
Ça ne part pas?
Bien sûr que non!
Je sais que tu adores mon travail.
Du coup, je t'ai pris une peinture
indélébile pour être sûre que ça
ne bouge jamais.
Ensuite, je t'ai pris un tapis
effet gazon parce que je sais que
tu adores le foot.
Je déteste le foot.
Je fais du basket.
Oui, bah, c'est les mêmes sports.
Et ensuite, je t'ai pris un assortiment
de nains de jardin que j'ai trouvés
chez ma grand-mère.
Mais je trouvais qu'ils iraient
tellement mieux chez toi.
C'est de la poubelle,
ça.
Tu as dit quoi?
Ça te plaît?
Non, ça ne me plaît pas!
J'aurais pas fait ça,
moi!
C'est pour ça que je suis là.
C'est pour te donner des idées
auxquelles tu n'aurais jamais pensé.
Et je suis ravie de savoir que
ça te plaît.
Mais je ne vais pas te mentir,
je m'y attendais.
En tout cas, en ce qui concerne
le fauteuil, il est vraiment pas mal,
mais il mérite un petit coup de
peinture.
Alors, n'hésite pas de m'appeler
pour ça.
Je ne t'appellerai pas.
Moi, je dois filer, j'ai un
rendez-vous.
Bisous les abonnés!
Allez, ciao!
C'est des malades.
C'est tous des malades.
Allô, EDF?
Oui, c'est Riad.
En fait, je vous appelle,
bon, je pense que c'est en dehors
de vos compétences, mais comme
vous êtes la seule personne de
mon entourage qui a un cerveau,
j'aimerais savoir si vous aviez
encore de bons plans pour repeindre
mon appartement, pour faire la déco?
Eh bien, toujours sur votre application
Check.
Vous avez de bons plans pour faire
repeindre votre appartement,
des réductions pour de la décoration.
Ça devrait pouvoir vous aider.
Je crois que je vous aime.
Pardon?
Hein?
Non, non, je vous laisse.
C'est super!
Ça fait plaisir de vous voir ici,
franchement!
En vrai, comme ça, je vous vois.
Moi aussi, je suis content de vous
voir en vrai.
Très heureux.
C'est rare qu'un client invite
un conseiller EDF à sa crémaillère.
Moi, c'est une première.
Et vos amis, ils ne sont pas encore
là?
Non.
En fait, j'ai invité que les gens
qui m'ont aidé.
Donc, il n'y a que vous.
Installez-vous!
Avec plaisir!
Mettez-vous à l'aise.
Vous voulez que je mette un peu
de musique?
Avec plaisir!
Vous voulez un truc en particulier?
Non, non, j'aime un peu tout alors…
Ah, j'ai oublié de m'occuper
d'Internet.
Ah, alors vous allez me dire que
je dis toujours la même chose,
mais l'application Check,
il y a de bons plans pour Internet,
pour la fibre.
L'application Check?
Mais oui, toujours la même.
Vous êtes vraiment quelqu'un
d'incroyable.
Vous voulez habiter avec moi?
Vous voulez faire une coloc?
Il faut que j'en parle à ma femme,
mais pourquoi pas?
Ah, vous avez une femme?
On l'appelle et on demande.
Allez!